the Celts actually had a very cool tree
based riding system called agum for a
long time I believe that most of Irish
mythology was lost to us because The
Druids past stories orally without
writing them down archaeologists have
found about 400 agum inscriptions on
Stones throughout Ireland Scotland and
Britain dating from the 4th to the 9th
centuries CE Scholars have figured out
that there are 20 characters in the
so-called tree alphabet with each letter
based on a different type of tree the
writing is read vertically from the
bottom to the top which is very rare for
a written language but nicely
reminiscent of how trees grow so the
next time you want to write a secret
message take some inspiration from the
ancient Celts and write in the language
of trees